claude lelouch je n'ose pas ce que je
peux vous demander de faire la claque
est mon dut rentrer jugé j'ai fait ça
toute ma vie
tout d'abord on me glisse à l'oreille
que vous étiez très heureux d'être à
montréal au festival ciné manière
pourquoi
d'abord parce que j'aime bien cette
ville vraiment j'ai à chaque fois je
suis venu ici je me suis senti à l'aise
là je pense que si un jour on me foutais
à la porte de la france je pourrais
avoir l'idée de venir ici
voilà je trouve que les gens c'est la
france sont des français la mairie sont
les américains c'est pas mal
vous êtes un grand amoureux du cinéma et
vous avez déjà dit que vous regardez au
moins un film par jour je suis curieux
de savoir ce que vous pensez le cinéma
québécois
par exemple pensez vous des fusils de là
bas je trouve que ça un metteur en scène
vraiment révolutionnaire qui a peur de
rien surtout pas de lui-même dans ses
films sont passionnants en france on
adore
je pense que c'est un garçon qui l'a de
film en film progresser aller très très
loin et n'a pas fini de nous étonner
comme dans les rondes tout finit en
beauté on finirait par s'aimer son amour
du cinéma est telle que je pense que
jusqu'à son dernier souffle il va faire
et de penser qu'à faire du filet maman
l'a annoncé il fait partie de ces gens
qui ont été faits pour faire ce métier
vous êtes un des plus grands
réalisateurs français j'aimerais savoir
comment vous voyez qu'un gars thater qui
avez quoi comme denis villeneuve perse
ainsi au niveau des réaliser un film
complet devant nous des mains car tout
ici son choix c'est son choix moi j'ai
refusé tout ce que ma propre jet à
hollywood après un homme et une femme
j'ai eu les plus belles propositions
qu'on pouvait je pense que je suis un
metteur en scène français j'ai une
culture
très européenne et je pense que j'aurais
trahi ma réflexion
si j'avais été faire des films de
producteurs voilà moi je fais des films
d'auteur et holyfield chine de
producteurs voilà donc alors vont tous
bien tout à leur âge ils ont fait des
chefs-d'oeuvre avec des films de
producteurs donc je vous déteste pas
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les films
des majors m'ennuie profondément
m'ennuie profondément parce que c'est
des jeux vidéo puisque les films et
j'imagine que l'as far west end vous a
quand même choqué oui elle m'a d'autant
plus choqué que je connais bien l'oiseau
il a distribué un de mes films edith et
marcel alors qu'il débutait dans ce
métier j'ai toujours été fasciné par son
enthousiasme cinématographie bouchage
je déteste l'idée de viol que ce soit
dans tous les domaines je dire que c'est
tellement formidable gens qui disent oui
voyez rien de plus beau que quand
quelqu'un vous dit oui voilà donc
je suis pas un violeur j'ai trop de
passion que j'ai trop de tendresse pour
les gens qui me disent oui chaque fois
j'ai pris beaucoup de femmes dans mes
bras mais elles m'ont toutes dit oui est
ce que je veux dire
et donc je pense que c'est un plaisir
qu'il auquel il n'a pas eu droit
voilà on m'annonce alors garé depuis je
suis pas là pour juger les gens est ce
qu'il ya un ménage afin sous les
plateformes
je crois que c'est partout qu'il faut le
faire ce ménage c'est pas uniquement sur
les plateaux de tournage la promotion
canapé elle et elle est aussi ancienne
que le plus vieux métier du monde
un pont il ya un vrai problème je vous
dire ce qui est étonnant aujourd'hui je
pense que les femmes devraient faire une
statue harvey puisque grâce à lui vont
pouvoir faire des grands changements
voilà mais ces changements il aurait pu
les faire il ya très longtemps parce que
ce harcèlement
il remonte à la nuit des temps
on
j'aime les femmes je veux dire que
j'éprouvais dans mes films que jamais
des femmes plus donc je les respecte
encore plus que tout et leur souffrance
me fait beaucoup de mal vie atteint
penser qu'on devriez quand tout va mal
parlons de vos films
un homme et une femme est sans aucun
doute le plus connu ouais mon préféré
c'est les uns et les autres
quel a été le moment d'épiphanie où vous
avez vu que le long plan séquence qui
tourne fonctionne très bien en cinéma
c'est quand j'ai tourné un homme et une
femme
dernier plan du film était avec anouk
aimée qui descendent des intrants et
elle savait pas que 30 ignorent aller la
rejoindre
je n'avais pas prévu qu'il y avait une
grande surprise et jamais être
intimement qui étaient cachés derrière
moi rire là cadrage les lâcher au
dernier moment et l'étonnement d'alice
mais à ce moment là tu es tellement su
que j'avais envie de voir son visage
toutes les façons je me suis rapproché
d'elle j'ai vu qu'il fallait
montrez n'y avait pas de trucage qu'on
était sur une vraie gare avec un vrai
train avec de vrais figurants de
trintignant était là pour devrait donc
j'avais envie film un parfum de vérité
donc à 20
qu'est ce qui vous pose encore
aujourd'hui à réaliser des films la
fantastique histoire d'amour que je lis
que le cinéma c'est une drogue
incroyable et je n'arrive pas à m'en
défaire je n'arrive pas à m'en défaire
et j'ai jamais eu autant envie de
tourner et que maintenant voilà mais je
pense que woody allen pourrait dire la
même chose clint eastwood ces jeux ds
que quelques mais je connais quelques
metteurs en scène aujourd'hui qui eux
aussi sont dans leur troisième mettant
et qui s'amuse de plus en plus je vous
laisse faire la claque à de la fin
claude lelouch a volé une claquette de
faim claquette de faim en fin de fin
pour vous un pas pour moi